Sharon got very emotional on the talk
today breaking the news that her husband
Ozzie is headed to sex rehab tell us
what's going on jaren tried to fight
back tears today when talking about
Ozzie
when it's somebody that has a sex
addiction it's um it's embarrassing
somehow drugs and drink is more
acceptable I think this all comes on the
heels of a statement from Ozzie that
he's currently undergoing intense
therapy quote over the last six years I
have been dealing with a sex addiction
he's working at it it's hard because it
affects the whole family the revelations
surfaced after Ozzy's former mistress
Michelle Pugh told People magazine that
it was isay who initiated their affair I
fell in love with a married man who
pursued me he was consistently willingly
and generously giving me his love but
from Ozzie I'm sorry if miss Pugh took
our sexual relationship out of context I
thank God that my incredible wife is at
my side to support me I'm proud that
he's come out and admitted it finally I
don't think it's the 20-somethings that
are obsessed with sex I think it's 67
year-old rocker and now comes a report
that Pugh is suing Ozzie and Sharon's
daughter Kelly remember the nasty tweets
Kelly sent out one of which accused Pugh
of elder abuse while reportedly in her
suit Michelle calls that not only wrong
but defamatory Pugh reportedly also
claims in her suit that she has lost
business as a celebrity stylist